with stimulus cash boosts pandemic
uncertainty and skyrocketing inflation
finances and financial standings are
more important to younger generations
than ever before
so it makes sense half of the eight
personal finance startups honored on
this year's fintech 50 list focused on
helping americans living paycheck to
paycheck find their financial footing
these honorees range from virtual credit
cards to travel bookings and all
honorees in this category are
collectively worth 38.8 billion dollars
here are the eight personal finance
startups that made the 2022 fintech 50
list in alphabetical order
bridget is a financial app helping
americans living on the edge build money
management skills and credit scores
the new york based company worth 600
million dollars offers a 9.99 monthly
subscription that links to the user's
bank account based on their cash flow
they can qualify for an interest-free
loan between fifty dollars and two
hundred and fifty dollars cto and
co-founder hamel kottari was a member of
the 2021 forbes 30 under 30 list
the largest digital bank in america is
chime
another honoree on this year's list
chime offers free checking accounts and
no overdraft fees ceo chris britt says
the san francisco-based company worth
around 25 billion dollars attracted more
new customers in the first quarter of
2022 than any quarter in the company's
10-year history isuzu is a new
york-based company that helps renters
build their credit for free by reporting
on-time rent payments to credit bureaus
the new york-based company worth one
billion dollars requires landlords to
pay because it increases on-time
payments reduces evictions and makes
more renters stay in units long-term
this santa monica-based company worth 26
million dollars is known as grow credit
they offer a virtual mastercard for
those with thin or no credit history
looking to boost their credit scores
this card ranges from being free to
costing eight dollars a month and has
about fifty thousand customers hopper is
a free app that predicts the cheapest
time to book flights or home rentals and
now allows customers to pay an extra fee
to freeze a flight's price for a week
even though the 5 billion company is
based in montreal canada nearly half of
its employees are us-based
next is propel
its providers app helps low-income
families with government benefits such
as food stamps and cash payments manage
their benefits alongside their overall
finances
the 520 million dollar company based in
new york has more than 5 million users
and ceo jimmy chen left a product
manager position at facebook to start it
in santa monica
tala makes 10 to 500 loans to customers
with little or no borrowing history in
the philippines mexico kenya and india
the 800 million dollar company uses
smartphone data to assess risk they are
planning on using a decentralized
finance cryptocurrency platform later
this year which will let professional
investors pool money to fund tala's
customers loans and earn a return
finally upgrade is a six-year-old
personal loan fintech that offers a
credit card similar to a personal loan
customers can get a credit line between
500 to 2500
have a fixed deadline to pay it off and
can make payments in equal monthly
installments
the san francisco company is worth 6.3
billion dollars and quadrupled its
annual revenue last year